[Music]
welcome to argument clinic a guide to
spotting flawed arguments on the
Internet and today we're going to talk
about the burden of proof this is the
question of who needs to provide
evidence for an argument and it comes up
a lot it cropped up during the pizza
gate affair when conspiracy theorists
were convinced that Hillary Clinton was
running an underaged prostitution ring
out of the bathrooms of a Washington DC
pizzeria after the wild speculation led
one man to fire an assault rifle inside
the restaurant Michael G Flynn the son
of Trump national security adviser pick
General Michael Flynn wake up America
and a member of Trump's transition team
at the time tweeted until Pizza Gate
proven to be false it'll remain a story
in other words it's not the
responsibility of the pizza gate
theorists to prove that their argument
is true it's the responsibility of pizza
gate critics to prove that it isn't
Flynn isn't the only guy asking
opponents to prove a negative after CNN
challenged Donald Trump's claim that
millions of people voted illegally he
retweeted this message from at
filibuster pathetic you have no
sufficient evidence that Donald Trump
did not suffer from voter fraud shame
bad reporter asking someone to prove a
negative is a classic dodge it shifts
the burden of proof from the person
making a claim to the person defending
against it and that is a bad basis upon
which to build an argument but don't
take my word for it ask the Byzantine
Emperor Justinian who back in the sixth
century established a set of laws that
included this gem proof lies on he who
asserts not on he who denies today we
call that the presumption of innocence
and it's the bedrock of the American
legal system the UN considers it a
universal human right you may have heard
that it's impossible to prove a negative
but that's not quite true mathematicians
do it all the time and so do scientists
but in the real world it is much
trickier for instance let's say I wanted
to argue that Bill Gates ate stroganoff
for breakfast this morning
now there's no reason to think this is
true but can you prove to me that it
isn't maybe you could get him on the
phone but short of that there's no real
way to know for sure that's why we
assess the likelihood of something being
true based on the quality of evidence
supporting it
we have no evidence that Bill Gates eat
stroganoff for breakfast and the fact
that I just pulled that lunatic example
out of thin air does not make it any
more likely to be true if I presented
compelling evidence that would change
things but absent that we have to assume
that he didn't so keep that in mind the
next time you hear someone insist some
claim is true unless you can disprove it
it's not up to you or anyone else to
disprove their claim it's on them to
prove
[Music]